but we're going to begin with the
breaking news overnight an unannounced
trip by President Biden to keep his
first since the Russian invasion and he
met with Ukrainian president zielinski
it comes at a critical moment in the war
against Russia and the president renewed
his pledge of American Support
remind us that freedom is priceless
it's worth fighting for
as long as it takes
and that's how long we're going to be
with you Mr President for as long as it
takes
we'll do it for as long as it takes he
says we've got Nancy Cordes with us from
Warsaw and Charlie dagada is in key if
we're going to start with Charlie who
was there when the president's met
Charlie the air raid sirens were going
off at one point it's a remarkable thing
to see an American president walking
through a war zone like that good
morning
it was Tony good morning to you it was a
visit shrouded in secrecy to say the
least President Biden has been here many
times before but this is the first time
since the War Began and even as he
walked with president zielinski in front
of the cathedral behind me those Air
Raid Sirens rang out adding to the
urgency of the proceedings now the
president was wearing a blue and yellow
tie in a show of solidarity he arrived
at the presidential Palace this morning
and met with the Ukrainian president
where he spoke briefly about his purpose
here he said to Mark the anniversary The
Invasion and to discuss further detail
on the situation on the ground the two
men then broke off for a one-on-one
meeting that lasted roughly two hours we
then gathered for the press conference
at the presidential Palace where the
president uh recalled a phone call that
he had with president zielinski on the
very morning of the invasion where
president zielinski described hearing
the explosions in the background
one year later Keith stands
and Ukraine stands
democracy stands
[Music]
now President Biden announced a military
aid package worth around 500 million
dollars largely more ammunition for the
high Mars and other weapon systems that
are already in use here he said he'd be
sharing the details in the coming days
president zielinski called the arms
package an unequivocal signal that
Russians Russia's attempt to win has no
chance after visiting St Michael's
Cathedral here the two men stopped
briefly to honor the war dead nearby the
president then made his way to the U.S
embassy to meet with staff there
this visit was as much about a show of
support to the people of Ukraine as it
was sending a message to President Putin
and Russia as President Biden put it he
thought he could Outlast us
he was wrong Nate
strong words Charlie Dagen and Keith
thank you